hurricane durian is accelerating up the
Florida coast right now while we learn
just how much devastation the storms
left in the Bahamas parts of the nation
of low-lying islands are in ruins two
more deaths were confirmed overnight
bringing the official total to seven the
country's prime minister says he expects
that number will rise this will give you
a sense of how hard durian hit take a
look before and after satellite images
show much of Grand Bahama Island was
left underwater durian is now moving
north as a strong category 2 storm
hugging the u.s. coastline hurricane
warnings are up along the coast in North
Florida and in the Carolinas our team of
correspondents is tracking it all but we
begin in the Bahamas with CBS this
morning's lead national correspondent
that's David beg no he's in the capital
of Nassau David I understand that's a
staging area for the rescues what's the
latest there well Tony if there's a bit
of hope this morning this sunrise is
some hope because it's new light on a
new day of searching here we're at the
airport because this is where people
who've been injured are being medevacked
and then taken to a local hospital this
is also where rescuers are staging to
take off in fact this morning if you
look out on the tarmac there's about a
half dozen people loading up a
helicopter as they get ready to take off
into an area where there is no cell
signal the reason we are in the Bahamas
the Nassau this morning is because we
have a signal to broadcast live and tell
you what's going on
the Bahamian prime minister got a ride
in the Coast Guard helicopter yesterday
and saw people waving for help below
they could not be rescued because the
conditions were so poor today they will
try again the extent of Dorian's
destruction across the northern Bahamas
is immense from the air
flying over Abaco island the damage
stretches from miles entire
neighbourhoods flattened homes shredded
shipping containers and boats hurled
inland some airports look like lakes now
this is the terminal of one of them
shrouded in debris we are in the midst
of one of the greatest nasty
crisis in our country's history durian
ravaged Abaco island and Grand Bahama
for two days with 30 inches of rain the
Red Cross has more than 13,000 homes
that's nearly half the number of those
two islands were damaged or destroyed
video from inside one home during the
storm shows waves crashing against the
second-story window as more water is
pouring in below pounding against the
stairs the United States Coast Guard
says it has rescued more than 45 people
after deploying several helicopters to
this region at this point we're still in
the early stages of the response we are
concentrating very much on parts fuel
people communications here the fact that
the storm was so slow to get out of here
and now that the infrastructure is
crippled it has delayed
search-and-rescue efforts leaving many
people to fend for themselves Tim Allen
a journalist working with The Associated
Press filmed himself and his family
abandoning their home in Freeport his
daughter is seen wading through life
threatening storm surge carrying one of
their animals people have been using
boats and jet skis even inflatable toys
to ferry other people to safety it came
over the roof Howard Armstrong decide
the gut-wrenching moment water flooded
his home and his wife died in front of
him she was standing on top of the
kitchen cabinets until they
disintegrated and then I kept with her
and then she just drowned on me it was
incredible to hear him talk about being
on that kitchen counter and watching his
wife succumb to what he believed was
hypothermia and then seeing her slip
under the water he was able to swim to
safety he found a boat and that's what
rescued him listen this morning there is
a Royal Navy vessel which is moving into
the area with more personnel and food
speaking of food a little bit later on
at 7:30 we've got the story of chef Jose
Andres and his team we went to their
hotel at midnight this morning got their
last meeting as they plan to prepare
thousands of meals wait until you hear
the fleet of resource
is that the chef has rented in order to
get out to the hardest hit areas today
we'll have that at 7:30 Maria Elena
thank you very much heartbreaking images
really they say that's the price of
living in Paradise but that's a high
price to pay
David thank you